alors attention maintenant on ne bouge
pas je préfère les draguer ou faire
draguer tu préfères draguer préféré
embrasser ou faire embrasser
ça dépend qui ouais c'est la joie le
coin préféré caresser ou faire caresser
elle consacre question je suis désolé
sont alors cela ne va pas sans l'autre
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
n'importe bonne réponse de christine ott
quel est le lieu où vous êtes incapable
de faire l'amour en revanche dans un
ascenseur a pour quelques immeubles sont
passées ou en france je vous ai besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer souvent les filles la
différence entre les filles et les gars
sont allés est-ce que vous préférez ah
oui un mec qui bosse bien avec un fidèle
ou un mec qui bosse mâles mais qui est
fidèle à essayer n'a pas vérifié c'est
compliqué comme question
c'est pas la mort de mon mari
vous préférez un mec ça vous tombe
dessus
bah oui ces interviews belge dont je
tairai à m eyepet maïs on peut vous le
faire
monsieur le maire jean louis harris
échoue à mais une fois on peut aussi
parler comme ça vous mais s'il est
plutôt à bruxelles ah oui moi j'adore ah
je croyais qu avec vous je suis ravi par
la sacem est frais comme en faut peu
finalement
ah oui dans le coup vous vous pensez
qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se dire je
vois qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut se
dire des choses qu'il ne faut pas ça
l'accord est-ce que vous avez des
fantasmes non encore réalisés bien sûr à
bord est bon un je ne dirai pas lesquels
je vous demande pas avec elle mais
maintenant j'essaye de précéder vous
voulez vous voulez réaliser que j'avais
dans l'idée de vous êtes vous acharner à
les réaliser et des idées comme ça
qu'ils aient encore des trucs à faire
quoi
chez robert laffont et maintenant mais
la mer